THE BIDENDMINTRATION JUS
CAT HP BUTSEHEKRAI
REFUGE CRIS T PUS TIR
THIS ORAGES COMMT. N
BEEN PBLEM IN ROPE FRO
THE SYRNR, EVEROM WHAT
MILLN PEOPL FOR T FD
PRODTIONAPACITY
LLAPD.
>> EG.
LOVHISALKIPALE.
AUGHR]
LIKE THE PBLEM OAVING ,
NGLE IDEOGICALLT.
EES EVETHG TOUGHHE
FILT OFIMAT HEOMESFF AS BUFONEC
PPLI I I NONCMATE
ISSUES
INSERTEVYWHE.
YO SEE MERN ACEMIC EEPT
EIRILTEIS ARICAS
DEPRESR.
CN THEIRILTER F YEA WAS
CE.
NORATIS.
SOMEDY WHO WAN TO B
CCESUL I LIFE IS TO VE ANUER O
E.
WHICH A TIM I AMAZG, B
HER TIM MAK ME IENTIVE
JERK.
TT'SHE PSM-
>> I THOHT THEREAS GEITIT
OTR PSM I
SOMEERE.
>> TRE I ONE.
>> THE ISON
DANAHAT EOUR TUGHTS O
THEUMAN -
>>OW I REAYINREST.
ALSO -- NOWE' CMA CZAR.
EA, LES DP T "CZAR"
HE'S MISON FOCUD.
WASHE SRETARY OSTAT
HAD ALL THESSUENDE
ULD HE PSON TYELP
ING  ME SETHI HAEN.
STD OFE'SALKING AUT
OD PRIS AR GNG T GP
GE OUTF TH BRE BASKE OF
THEORLDN UKRNE ANDRUIA.
THEREIGHTPRISINGSOT
NECESSILY CAUS OLIMA
CHAN, BUT BAUSE OTHEOST
OF FOO LIK WT HAENEDN
>> CZY IHE EAS WITTHE
WHEA
HAVEEEN UPRTEDYTHIS. AN MILON M
YOU HA ENTE POPATIO ON
THEMOVE
IS I THEIGGE REFEE
SYA - EUPE. ANIST AND
WEST. PLE STAOING
AT WT POI WILL POLANDAY
ENOU, IAN'T HDLE-
PAA.
HEN E WE GNG TO SRT
TANGHESE REFEES?
>>HE VICE ESIDT --
>> SMS WE'REAKG EVYBODEL IN.
TH ARESCAPING WAR. >>HESE A FR
THERE PEOE W BIEVEN
E SE THIS WEELIE IN.
THEI FILS ATAYINGACK
TO FHT F FREEDOM A F
THR COTRY.TH BELVE INRAIN
THEYELIE IN THE MISON.
WANT THE HE.
>>OUHINK BIN'S WORED
MIGH VE REBLICAN?FEES
>> I SHOEAD HAST IITED
>> TT' A GOO ANE.
BIDE DSN'T WAN UAINIAN
REFUGE BECSE THEY LL VE
REPUICAN